Hey, everybody, welcome to the
content video going over section
1.9 of your textbook, Other
Popular Programming Languages.
So one of the reasons I
like to talk about other
programming languages is because
there's a lot of programmers
out there and a lot of
programmers won't just use
one language. They'll use
all sorts. So, for example,
maybe you use Python primarily, but
you also incorporate JavaScript or
R programming into your programs.
and that's a pretty common practice
is that a lot of programmers will
use multiple different languages.
And it's good to be aware of some
of them. And all of these ones
that I'm going to talk about right
here are high level languages. So
if you remember from a previous
video, we talked about there's high
level languages, assembly languages,
machine languages, and these
are all going to be high level
languages, which means that they are
human readable and writable. And
once they're all written and run,
the operating system will take them
as machine code to the CPU, which
will then do whatever is programmed.
So without further ado, let's
talk about some of these. So we've
got BASIC developed in the 90s.
C was developed in the, or sorry, in
the 90s. Wow, I can't read. The 1960s.
C was developed in the
1970s. So these are older
languages. Hopefully maybe
you guys have heard of some
of them because they have
been around for so long.
I've mentioned in another video
that C is kind of a root language
for many other programming
languages, right? So, it's used
for a lot of other operating
systems. It's used for the kernel.
When it was created initially,
it was called Unix, which
is a word that maybe some of
you have seen floating around.
And then C++, which also you may
have heard of, is a language that's
similar to C, but as you can maybe
guess, the++ kind of implies that there
have been features or add-ons. And
so it's just a kind of fancy way
of saying that there's C plus some
capabilities for object-oriented
programming, as you can read right
here. And we are actually going to talk
about object-oriented programming a
little bit later on in the course.
But basically, objects are a
way in code to represent things
in the real world. So for
example, a person, a university,
a car, cell phone stock those are
all real world things that we can
represent with objects in our code
and objects are kind of like data that
have functionality so um that's
all that we'll talk about right now
but c++ is object oriented um let's
move on to java so java is another
really really common coding language,
also object-oriented coding language.
And the thing that made it so
popular was that it was able to be
written once and run anywhere. So
it was a lot, it was able to be run
on a wider variety of machines.
There weren't as many stipulations to
using it, and it was great for
developing applications with something
called a GUI, which stands for graphical
user interface. So that's Java.
And then C sharp, another
derivative of C is
Microsoft's answer to Java.
So Java was getting really,
really popular back in the
day. And Microsoft said,
well, let's come up with
another language that will be
a rival to Java. And that's
where C sharp came from.
And C sharp, I believe is an open,
oh yeah, right here, open source
language.
So, another really important
one to note is JavaScript.
JavaScript is an incredibly common
language because it's used so widely,
and it's very, very strong with,
or sorry, very commonly used with
building websites. In fact, the
Codespace and GitHub that we use in
this course is actually coded using
JavaScript and TypeScript, which is
not one that I have that we'll talk
about in this video. But JavaScript
is incredibly commonly used to
make robust websites. So I think
Facebook is coded with JavaScript,
which probably means that Instagram is
as well. Some pretty big websites.
I think maybe Amazon could be wrong
there. It's really pretty impressive.
So if you've ever made anything
in JavaScript, you'll know that to
have something that works as well
as something like Facebook or
GitHub, to have it work as well as it
does requires quite a bit of programming.
So JavaScript is really cool.
And one of the reasons it's called
JavaScript is because people
wanted it to appeal to people who
knew Java. And so some of the syntax
is pretty similar in JavaScript
and Java. So if you knew Java,
JavaScript is probably somewhat developed
or sorry, somewhat familiar to you.
And then there's Swift, which is an
Apple programming language and not
as common today. You'll see it
sometimes, but it's not as widely used.
And then R is a language that you
might see as somebody who's taking
a data analytics course. You may
have been exposed to R programming
since it's widely used in statistical
applications and visualizations.
And so Python and R are two most
widely used data science languages.
So that about wraps up. Oh, actually,
sorry. We're almost done with this video.
In the code that I had you guys
pull for the semester, I have
included a couple of samples
of different types of code and
what they look like. Oh, it's
not that one. That one's broken.
So you can see we've got C. I think
this one is C Sharp. we've got HTML,
Java, Python, and Ruby and
these different codes are all
doing the exact same thing
they're just printing out hello
world to the console so you
can check those out and look at
what some other programming
languages might look like and
that wraps up everything for
this video thanks for watching